are you familiar with the red salute no
have you seen the black lives matter
fist they show in the in the
yeah is is that is that is that does
that symbol appear in north korea
i mean like during this day yeah oh yeah
totally that's every time like let's
kill our american bastards our enemies
oh you raised the fist
yeah so this the the the it's the it's
the red salute it's the communist fist
um you guys might notice i was reading
that when someone
is joining the chinese communist party
they they perform the red salute
they call it yeah i mean you have to
like raise your fist and pledge your
life to the party essentially
as yeah this this uh well july 1st is
the 100 year anniversary of the
communist party
and there's this phenomenon of red
tourism where people are going around
dressing up like old red guards and
they're doing the salute and they
they go to get glitches you go take a
you know instagram photo of you
doing the red salute and pledging your
life to the party
you know that's disneyland that's the
flag of black lives matter
it's the it's the symbol twitter used
for juneteenth yep
yeah and they say it's the black power
fest and i'm like
yeah i guess the roman salute which the
nazis used is the white powerful
or so whatever it doesn't matter to me i
mean these are these are these are
salutes to the ideology
and it's oppressive and uh
i i don't want to be alarmist yeah by
saying oh it's clearly happening here
but
you look at the embassies flying these
flags the u.s embassy is now using these
the
the symbolism you see people marching
through the street in defiance of
edict from governors when they did the
lockdowns and they're performing the red
salute
they give it a different name but it's
the same symbol the same flag the people
who
are organizing black lives matter say
they are trained marxists or at least
some of them do
and critical race theory which is the
the big battle in the culture war right
now
is uh literally rooted in critical
theory
from the traditional marxist school of
thought and they try and deny it
but every day i i feel i do feel
optimistic especially today
with you know seeing these these
families loudoun county they're standing
up they're challenging the stuff
but i i feel like you know these people
these these families are worried about
what their kids are being taught are
putting themselves on the line
i'm i'm worried that if too many people
are scared and they remain
scared we inch closer towards a reality
where you can no longer speak out
anymore i mean we have the poem we know
what happens when you don't speak out in
defense of others
so it feels like we're we're heading in
that direction i think there was a viral
video of some woman it was like a
chinese woman who was talking about i
don't know if this was loudon or
somewhere else
but yeah she was a like a chinese parent
and she was saying this is just like the
cultural revolution
which i went through in china and a lot
of people kind of were offended by that
because there
you know possibly 20 million people died
during the cultural revolution so
some people are like oh well that's
you're being too crazy if you're
comparing this to the cultural
revolution
but you know if you the the hallmark of
the cultural revolution was the struggle
session
right which is struggle under chinese
communism is a verb
where you struggle someone you bring
them into a room
everybody in their workplace or
everybody in your neighborhood
like if it was a very prominent person
they would fill stadiums
to denounce these people like the person
would stand there they'd be
made to hold some kind of like torture
posed so that they're
like the airplane or something where
they're like uncomfortable they'd have
like a placard put on them that says
what their crimes are
right and then people would scream at
them yell at them
humiliate them shame them throw things
at them this is a struggle session
and it's like well if you think of that
as what the cultural revolution was
doing to people
you know we don't struggle people in the
u.s we cancel people
in the u.s yeah and we can cancel them
online we don't have we can ruin
people's lives
on twitter we don't have to bring them
into a room to yell at them we can just
make them lose their jobs how is it that
you know china and north korea are so
different i suppose
right they went through a cultural
revolution they had purges they have a
communist party with the red salutes and
all that stuff but
china still has massive cities and
wealth and technology and food
probably a lot of that is just the
ability of china to
accept investment from the west china
really changed after mao died
mao because you know his political
purges basically
like killed almost 80 million people
probably so between the great leap
forward the famine
the you know cultural revolution like he
he was just
killing so many people and then the next
generation of chinese leaders
were basically like okay we're communist
but this is not sustainable
so they kind of and a lot of them were
people who were purged by mao like xiao
ping so they were like
we're going to uh open our markets
they call it reform and opening up and
it wasn't really
the state was still involved like the
state still owned the means of
production but they were kind of like
we'll give people the ability to at
least make money on a small scale
you can have businesses you don't have
to work for the state
uh western investment can come in
and bring the money i remember reading a
story about like
after mao died like the first people who
were like
made a contract and like for them it was
like oh
that we might die for this like we might
be killed for this it was like the first
test of like will this reform and
opening up actually happened so
so what year was that around 1978. so
that's when they finally started i guess
modernizing and getting
more technology and things to improve
and then because china is such a massive
market there's so many people there to
work
right manufacturing companies wanted to
come in
companies germany came in in the 70s to
start like
building their volkswagen very early
yeah so like
building their auto plants there already
uh and also people see it as a big
market where people can buy things now
so i think that's the real difference
but like structurally it's not that
different from north korea
uh you know north korea ecologically
ideologically and structurally people
like to pretend that china is not
communist anymore because they have
uh you know a certain thing like they
have a stock market
but you can't own property in china
still
wow like the state owns all the land
still you can
buy a lease on the land for
70 years interesting and that's what
you're buying when you buy real estate
or you can buy an apartment
in an apartment building but you cannot
actually own land all the land is still
owned by the state
and there is no real private companies
it's it's
maybe state-owned enterprises otherwise
it's owned by a son or daughter of a
party official
or every company every school
everything in china basically has a
communist party
cell inside of it and there's a party
secretary there watching everything
so the party's involved there is no free
enterprise
in china isn't it every single company
has to have
a a party member yeah specifically whose
job is to be a party member for the
company or something like
the party secretary yeah yeah work work
that's happening here in the us
with the diversity inclusivity and
equity officers
in in all these companies i mean it's a
job that performs no
no function other than to be
ideologically pure well that's the
that's a strange thing about all this
like i've seen some reactions to like
you're like you own me talking about
woke
in america and then and people get
really upset about that
oh that's ridiculous or as shelley
mentioned the chinese woman who's like
hey this has reminded me of the cultural
revolution
and if you only focus on like the
differences like obviously the united
states is not north korea yeah
but somehow those societies became the
way they
were there is an evolution that happens
and i think the problem is people don't
realize or understand
what marxism is they don't understand
what communism is
like what is the problem of trying to
create an equal society what's the
problem of trying to
teach people about slavery that's not
bad
so why are you saying that this is like
the cultural revolution
every i think every example of
the the path to the utopia turned out to
be a path to hell
yeah by design yeah right well i
you know what i think happens to i think
there's a i know a lot of these
activists on the left and they're very
utopian they're very optimistic
idealistic and they're like we can
create this beautiful
utopia so long as we all just agree on
how things work
well it starts with 10 people them and
their friends
and they all say hey i work today and
i'm going to share with you my bounty
and they say thank you very much i did
the dishes for you and then
it goes up to 20 people but then one
person says i'm not going to share with
you
my you know my pizza i i made this piece
of myself it's only enough for me i'm
starving i'm hungry
and they say okay this person's got to
go because
no matter what we say they won't agree
with us when it scales up to a certain
point
and you have you're now locked to
borders of a country
yeah and you can't just say we're gonna
leave and do our own thing
well then what happens is they say you
know we have this really great utopia
except for those people well what do we
do with them
guess you gotta get rid of them and what
ends up happening every single time
they get rid of them and there are
people who will argue with that but that
basically is what it says in the
communist manifesto that to
create this equal utopian society you
have to overthrow
all pre-existing social conditions uh
like
the family like religion well what
happens if somebody doesn't want to give
up their religion
what if somebody likes their family
what do they like private property this
is why i wonder
about you know north korea you know
you're saying that you don't have these
concepts
you don't understand love and things
like that the color thing was
amazing like that that's something that
kindergartners have they
you learn your colors what's your
favorite color yeah which one just do
you
and i remember being a little kid and
they have a bunch of colors
and they're like which one is your
favorite and i'm like i don't know i
said green you know why because
my birthday's in march and the calendar
for march was always green
so i just said green like they just left
it upon me
as a child who had no real understanding
of what it meant to have a favorite
color
to just say it yeah and i was like green
clearly green is not my favorite color
today
[Laughter]
you know you you good point about that
is like a lot of the problem people have
with like this critical race theory
stuff that's going around
especially when it's being taught
through like k through 12.
like whatever it is as a university
subject
you're a college student you're a fully
foreign person
but like if you're talking in
kindergarten you don't even have a real
sense of your own
self-identity and yet you're already
being put into these classes
see what's interesting
technically they aren't teaching
critical race theory
because they're arguing oh we don't
bring up the literature of
race and policy what they're doing is
they're
teaching the the core thesis of critical
race theory
within other subjects so imagine
here's why i described it imagine if a
bunch of parents decided that the new
math curriculum
would be something like here's a math
problem a child encounters
jeremiah has 10 bibles in order to
worship the lord properly he must
distribute
seven of them to his neighbors if he
doesn't he will burn in hell
how many bibles does he have after he
distributes the ones the lord requires
like if that was an actual math problem
in schools parents would be like
yo like they're not teaching the bible
they're not teaching christianity
no what are you talking about not we've
never mentioned scripture
nobody's reading from the bible you're
crazy and then
you look at the math you look at the
math problem you're like this is just
this whole thing
so they're finding subversive ways to
indoctrinate kids but it's also
incorporated in their policies
and the scary thing is it's become
inherent now where you have these
schools
that don't even recognize they exist in
this alternate reality
they just it's normal to them that's
that's where that's where it starts
like you mentioned these countries all
ended up these ways
that's what i find truly interesting uh
so uh obviously a lot of people know
that i'm part korean
and uh because you know tim pool's mixed
race like a meme i say it all the time
because we're talking about
you know race policy and identitarianism
but uh uh actually my great grandfather
is from a city
in the north at the time there was no
north so for my family
leaving korea coming to the united
states and all that stuff
these these concepts of a north and
south and this conflict didn't exist at
the time
something happened where all of a sudden
the city where my great-grandfather is
is worlds apart from the city where my
great-grandmother was from
and i think my great-grandmother was
from seoul and my great-grandfather was
from hey
hiju hey june yes yeah now i mean at the
time
they were probably identical in many
ways like same culture same language
same history
now they're just absolutely different oh
yeah i'd imagine the people in the north
like you mentioned
they think they have this god they have
this new religion the history has
changed
yeah something happened to make it that
way and now that that impacts you know
even me and
and other people whose history sort of
stops at these these conflicts
the historical revisionism that's
happening in the united states is what
what scares me and that's why i kind of
you know related to these circumstances
i mean north korea also had like a speed
run at this in a certain way because
it was the soviet union after world war
ii that got north korea right like
the treaty was we split it along the
38th parallel
that the the western democracies they
get south korea
russia the soviet union gets north korea
so you guys kind of had like
like a crash course in this in a certain
sense where like you know now suddenly
kim jong
kim wilson is put in and he's like
taking soviet stuff and then
using it to build his own identity cult
and all this stuff so it's kind of
it's kind of crazy to look at north
korea too because this is like
this is like the you know like the super
powered version
of what happens i mean the thing is like
what shocks me about north korea they
began like communism right
promising oh i'm gonna give you free
health care free education
free housing free every i mean nothing
is free but they say everything is free
so they did that in the beginning from
the soviets they got subsidies
so they were giving rations to people
for free
in the 90s they stopped the soviet union
collapsed what did they do
they changed their ideology to
self-reliance
so now they don't care about you you
take care of yourself by the way you
have no freedom to trade
do nothing so how do you survive that's
why like
30 million people died in the 90s in the
northern parts
if you secretly grew a tomato plant or
something in your base in like you hit
it in your house
would they would they execute you if
they found it no i mean if you hide it
really well
yeah like let's say you're you're
starving yeah so you secretly grow some
plants
it's okay it's okay yeah yeah you're
allowed to grow your own food or
no we cannot own the land it's
collectivism we work collectively in the
farm
and then the government takes eighty
percent and twenty percent is divided
between the covenant of fishers
and then they just no memories don't
give you anything it's like the
stupidest thing i've ever heard to be
honest
like it's an inefficient way to run a
system to even benefit themselves
i think this is why china was like hey
let's take investment we want to be rich
and successful now there's no
there's more chinese millionaires than
there are american millionaires they've
made themselves wealthy and powerful
why doesn't north korea do it he's just
getting too scared
he's very scared and all he needs is
nukes right
so he's he doesn't want to change and
he's comfortable
he's been he's been so good at this why
would he change
anything right they've been so
successful at this for almost 80 years
they've been doing this
and i think um even kim jong-un
is a victim of the same brainwashing at
this point
yeah certainly he's in charge and he
understands it more and and knows more
than regular people he was educated in
the west
but he was also very much indoctrinated
you have to run this country you have to
be in charge
and so his world view is is now a
product
of their own manipulation yeah it's kind
of crazy because i'm sure uh kim il-sung
had he had an understanding of global
affairs in world politics
he probably understood you know he was
marxist he was a leninist
for sure yeah i'm sure he but but he
knew about russia he knew about
the world and then he told everyone he
was god
yeah and then you know his son was in
the 70s trying to
be nice to his father because he had a
lot of concubines and sons right
so there's a competition that came the
game of thrones
remember this happened in malaysia
literally they are killing each other to
get there
so he was saying in the 70s oh i want to
get this drone from my father so now i'm
going to make him god
so he did all propaganda making him kim
can move the mountains
knows what you think like everything
begin there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you